at 40. yeah what kind of fear should I
expect to see what kind of fear yeah it
actually it starts getting less fearful
you start realizing all the dumb [__]
you're worried about doesn't [__]
matter high school high school is 25
years ago bro 25 years ago in their 30s
or 40s they start the process of finally
not overvaluing other people's opinions
this is why garyvee exists helping
people win that battle live your life
for you not for your parents not for
your spouse not for your siblings for
you when can you get there when can you
do something that you're not scared if
they're gonna make fun of you that
doesn't mean be delusional that doesn't
mean be disrespectful it means when are
you finally ready to be comfortable in
your own skin for my observations
mid 30s late 30s early 40s you see
people starting to click in sure